winter adventures in the snow you need a
vehicle with all-wheel drive to cope
with these extreme conditions and no one
knows how to deal with snow and ice
better than the sweets from the outside
the new cross-country model doesn't look
very different from a standard B 90
apart from its protective body cladding
and a ground clearance of 21 centimeters
it also comes with typical volvo LED
headlights the crossover model aims to
combine design with functionality
our contestant Michelle Austin mother
says she thinks the Volvo v90 cross
country looks just as great insight as
out because it's well-made and feels
good to the touch the digital and
touchscreen displays almost lend the car
a futuristic look this is not completely
new terrain for Volvo the Swedish car
makers brought out their first cross
country model 20 years ago the smaller
v70 XE with the v9 t cross country Volvo
wants to give motorists the freedom to
get out and about in the country without
the need for an SUV
in Norfolk and Michelle says that
driving the v90 cross-country is
practically like driving an SUV the
additional ground clearance means a
higher ride had a better view of the
road and the hood all-wheel drive comes
as standard in the luxury vehicle we're
testing the most powerful diesel d5 pro
with an output of 173 kilowatts it takes
the practically two-ton vehicle 7.5
seconds to accelerate from zero to 100
kilometers an hour and German ich the
car will set you back around sixty three
thousand five hundred euros
deaf halt nonces our car tester says the
v90 cross-countries road-holding feels
as stable as a train on a track but it
has plenty of go at the same time as
soon as she'd not just the accelerator
the car really takes off you can choose
from four different types of engine with
performance outputs ranging from 140 to
200 35 kilowatts Volvo wants access to
as many possible markets worldwide
Michelle says that it's fun to drive the
cross country on normal roads now she's
going to really put it through his paces
and see how it performs and snow and ice
to safely test the car we are using a
special track but first we're going to
switch off the electronic stability
control on rough ground the v90 cross
country becomes a real fun ride
our car tester says she would never
normally disable the electronic
stability control function and drive
around on an icy stretch at 30 to 40
kilometers an hour but here it's really
enjoyable and thanks to the all-wheel
drive the car quickly regains control
driven like this the tail does swing out
a bit in the curve but it quickly gets
back on track
you need a sensitive touch but it's
great fun
[Music]
the Volvo v90 cross country isn't just a
safe choice for on-road driving
conditions it's also really fun off-road
this is not just a practical sensible
car it's also a toy for grown-ups and
should be its equity guns Coulson's
you